the Joe Rogan experience yourself or do
you have to have somebody do it I could
do it to myself I'm not a [ __ ] I need
to go some doctor stick a robot dick in
my butt
come on suck you like bungee jumping and
your robot dick fell out and then also
you know sadness in the middle of the
day that would be crazy
look we're already doing that with pills
right people that are addicted to xanax
and I know a few that [ __ ] apparently
makes you feel great it's at the upper a
downer
that's the there's no no problems in the
world drug that's it's an anxiety
reliever and the people that take it man
they get hooked on that [ __ ] Dom my rare
is very open about it he takes that [ __ ]
every day
he's so great he's great you had him
last night on kill tone he's the best of
that no one's better at kill Tony the
dumber yeah he's so quick you know and
he knows like the most ridiculous [ __ ]
to say yeah but he likes them xanax I
know a lot of Stanhope like xanax - he's
just joking around about if he got out
of a plane and kissed the floor when he
when he landed in America because he saw
his antics on the ground they love those
things I'm scared of that [ __ ] I don't
want I don't want anything that makes me
feel like there's no problems I think
the only reason why a lot of people
don't do it is because they don't have a
friend that has a bunch of xaniix that's
constantly given them xanax or something
cause I never see pills or you know I'm
not around that Roda at all I like I
don't even what as xanax looks like you
know you know but I bet if you we had a
friend that always had xanax on him
always great many ones antics you know I
bet that's how you get into it I think
somebody just tells you you need to
relax you know so much anxiety I mean
the world is filled with possibility the
world is filled with danger the world is
filled with good things and bad things I
mean there's a lot of [ __ ] going on if
you don't have some anxiety it must be
because you're just choosing to not pay
attention like anybody who lives in New
York City you live in New York City
imagine all the [ __ ] that's going on
around you all the time while you're
just sitting there you're supposed to be
aware of it
just supposed to hope everybody keeps
together supposed to help everybody's
cool you're you're in your apartment
you're on the thirteenth floor of a
sixty floor building it's filled with
people there's another one right next to
it there's another one right next to
that they go all the way down the street
they're filled with people people are
[ __ ] everywhere and you're supposed
to just be chilled out that doesn't make
no sense to me man
I'm I'm with you if you're nervous if
you're anxious you're driving in traffic
every day and people are on their phones
and they're not paying attention and
everything you eat gives you cancer
you're not you're not anxious I don't
understand you
you should be anxious you know this is
the argument for not living the way we
live it's not the argument for taking a
pill that kills that part of your brain
that makes you anxious do you oughta
beliefs I a lot mostly for humor yeah I
don't
audibly sigh like by myself like oh but
I'll do it like that like for a joke oh
I catch myself more audibly sighing more
and more the order I get like just like
little things where I'll just like look
at something oh that kind of you know
but I didn't used to do that like I'm
gonna go to oh boy it's like the things
I grew up with or even is it culture
appropriation I have to ask my Jewish
friends from law to start saying oh eh
yeah cuz like nobody ever got mad at
anybody wasn't Italian he would say
motto not on this girl nobody cares
about those you like the use of like
fungal it isn't Jersey go to these
coasts go to where those old-school
guineas were landed on boats and [ __ ]
each other on the rocks and made a bunch
of them and they all stayed there about
fungal what'swhat's the Italian horn
like if you're Italian as your [ __ ] I
don't know I don't know where it came
from we all had him in high school
though it was like if you had a gold
chain with a horn like wow look it's
stylish did not know that thing existed
it's called the comma cell
I've seen that sperm before that's
probably what it is
[Applause]